this is me at age seven and this is also
me to be standing here in Kakuma refugee
camp feels so surreal and I'm overcome
with so much emotion these very grounds
are where I was born and spent the first
seven years of my life I think many
people are surprised to hear that I had
a great upbringing here at Kakuma but I
was happy I was smart I had friends and
above all I had hope for a brighter
future that's not to say that we didn't
have our obstacles I mean boy were their
struggles I would sometimes get sick
with malaria and didn't always know
where our next meal would come from but
the sense of community that is here in
Kakuma and the pride that everyone here
possesses is simply unparalleled when I
was younger I remember conflicts
breaking out that tends to happen when
people come from different backgrounds
and don't speak the same language
eventually Swahili the main language
here became our common ground I made
friends with the kids at the camp and
even started embracing some of their
cultures celebrating holidays like
Christmas even though I was raised
Muslim the other kids would embrace my
culture as well sometimes even praying
right alongside me it was easy as
children to come together blend all of
our beliefs to form our own unique
multicultural environment
my name is Halima Evan and I'm a Black
Muslim somali-american from Kenya
some have called me a trailblazer I was
the first Muslim homecoming queen at my
high school
the first Somali student senator and my
college and the first hijab wearing
woman in many places like the Miss
Minnesota USA beauty pageants the
runways of Milan in New York Fashion
Week's and even on the historic cover of
British Vogue as you can see I'm not
afraid to be the first to step out on my
own
to take risks and seek change because
that's what being a minority is about
it's about using yourself as a vessel to
create change and being a human
representation for the power of
diversity and now I use my platform to
spread an important message of
acceptance but it hasn't always been
easy when we first arrived to the United
States and made st. Louis Missouri home
I remember asking my mom is this really
America there were things that were
sadly familiar like hearing gunshots at
night and the streets looking
impoverished but there are things that
were also very different like when I
started first grade I noticed how the
kids played in groups in America we call
them cliques back here we all played
together gender didn't matter and race
most certainly never mattered I remember
asking myself why don't they understand
Swahili Swahili is the language that
brings people together to make matters
worse the school I was enrolled in
didn't have an English immersion program
so every day I would get up go to school
sit in my desk and never learn a thing
this is when I started losing hope and I
wanted nothing more than return to
Kakuma
a refugee camp so when my mother learned
that many Somalis found refuge in a
small town in Minnesota so when I was 8
we moved to Minnesota my life changed as
I met other students who spoke Somali
attended a school that had an English
immersion program and found teachers
that would go above and beyond staying
there after school hours and lunch
breaks dead
to helping me find success in the
classroom being a child refugee has
taught me that one could be stripped of
everything
food shelter clean drinking water even
friendship but the one thing that no one
could ever take away from you is your
education so I made studying my top
priority and soon started flourishing
within the classroom as I grew older I
became more aware of others and how they
viewed my race and background
specifically when I started wearing the
headscarf known as a hijab when I first
started wearing it I was excited
I remember admiring my mother's and I
wanted to emulate her beauty but when I
started middle school the students
teased me about not having hair so to
prove them wrong I started showing them
my hair something that goes against my
beliefs but something I felt pressure to
do I wanted so badly to fit in at the
time when I reflect on the issues of
race religion identity a lot of painful
memories come to mind it would be easy
for me to blame those of another culture
for making me feel the pain I felt but
when I think deeper I also recognize
that the most impactful positive
life-changing events that have happened
to me are thanks to those people who are
different than me it was at this moment
that I decided to step outside of my
comfort zone and compete in a pageant
wearing a hijab in burqini
I saw it as an opportunity to be a voice
for women who like myself have felt
underrepresented and although I didn't
capture the crown that experience opened
so many doors for me I was receiving
emails and messages from women all over
the world telling me that I've inspired
them by simply staying true to myself
the other firsts kept coming I was
invited to New York City by fashion icon
Kareem Rothfeld to shoot my very first
editorial it was around this time that I
became the first hijab wearing model and
in my first year I graced the cover
of nine fashion magazines it was a world
when to say the least but with all the
overnight success there is one thing
that remained constant the thought that
this could be what brings me back here
to Kakuma the place that I call home in
just a few months ago something
incredible happened to me I was in New
York City on a photo shoot when I met
South Sudanese model a dude a catch who
also happened to be born right here in
Kakuma that experience in itself is the
definition of hope I mean just imagine
two girls born in the same refugee camp
reunited for the first time on the cover
of British Vogue I was given the
distinct pleasure of partnering up with
UNICEF knowing firsthand the work that
they do for children in need and I want
you to remember that although the
children here may be refugees they are
children they deserve every opportunity
to flourish to hope to dream to be
successful my story began right here in
Kakuma refugee camp a place of hope
thank you
you
[Music]